welcome back to another episode of trash
taste I'm Connor and I'm with the boys
as usual Joey and gone that's them
they're the boys
we need to learn how to podcast again
because it's been the first time we've
been in the studio for like maybe well
we never left but uh in real life we did
leave to a lot of different places it's
been five weeks it's been a long time
since we've been in since we've been in
the podcast Studio Church of America
twice yeah you did oh yeah you did
because Hawaii is America yeah yeah true
yeah Cycles all across Kyushu I always
forget the week's work I always forget
Hawaii's America yeah yeah I know you're
busy I forgot about that until well I
knew about that but for for some reason
I would hope so yeah yeah I I knew but
like for some reason there was always
this like mental Gap where Hawaii is
Hawaii even though like it's you know an
American state I still always felt that
Hawaii is its own separate thing in my
mind
um even though it's not uh and then I
went and then we went to Hawaii and I'm
like oh this is actually America okay
this this is actually a America it's uh
yeah we uh just went to Hawaii for uh
Kawaii con which was very very fun it
was making mention mine in first
Corner's trip to Hawaii how was it it's
all right
always guys Hawaii's definitely a good
place I should never ask a British
person if something's good or not yes
the answer would just be it's like it's
like Disneyland for adults if you ever
go to Hawaii you just kind of feel like
the instead of like you know when you go
to certain parts in like Spain they'll
have like a resort it just seems like a
whole island or at least that's part of
this well especially Waikiki yeah just
turned into like a resort for people
with too much money and want to drink
alcohol or wasn't it something like I
think I think you or something with a
cameraman for something and the
cameraman who lived there for like 30
years yeah he told me that Hawaii
[__] we manufacture
um he told me that Hawaii has one
million people who live on it yeah like
locals yeah people who live there but at
any given time there's 10 million people
on the island
it's like a ratio of like wanted it's
like token like yeah
a lot of it's a lot of a lot of tourists
um but like most of them stay in the
where we were which is like Waikiki
which I guess is the touristy part it's
basically like yeah it feels like a
Disneyland but for adults yeah Kyle were
they capping or I have a 6.7 million
visitors compared to 1.4 million
residents
so it's like five to one pretty much
it's still insane yeah considering
because that means like when you're
looking you're walking around or driving
like you're almost always looking at a
tourist without realizing it or
especially if you're in like Waikiki
which we were for them yeah yeah yeah I
mean I would have liked to explore more
of the other Islands because like Hawaii
was like incredible but I think my
mental image of Hawaii before going did
not add up to the image that I landed in
what was your mental image of Hawaii I
don't know maybe Island like yeah a bit
maybe a bit more like Island like maybe
a bit you know closer to Nature or stuff
like that you know I've traveled to like
different Tropical Islands before yeah
and obviously there was you know there
have been like big cities on some of
these islands but nothing that really
compared to Waikiki yeah it's kind of
felt like Kona said it was like kind of
like a theme park I landed and I'm like
oh [__] it's spring break 24 7. every
day of the year that's kind of what it
felt like I felt bad for the locals they
have to deal with that [__] yeah I'm
sure that's what I'm sure that's what a
Kyoto feels like to the locals that live
there yeah probably probably pretty much
the same yeah I mean I'm British I was
like yeah it's all right I'm not a big
beach guy not a fan of beaches that's
why he's so quiet I honestly I gotta
avoid that you're blending into that
[__] dude I I normally stay away from
beaches I'm not I just I why okay why
are you not a beach person that's what
I've always wanted to know because
you've said this sand actually is the
worst feeling thing now Luke Skywalker I
think that people mock their scene and I
thought he's right like I don't send is
like just something that I despise and
when I'm on it I can't relax so would
you prefer it if it was a Pebble Beach a
Rock Beast no I don't want any beat
let's let's all get sand into this sand
isn't
[Music]
I I just like I if we could have like
just the pool kind of setup but for all
of the ocean like I can climb out and I
could be done that that is the most
privileged scene thing you've said in a
long time I've said a lot of privilege I
know it has been zero days I don't like
sand like it just sucks
I like because it's like okay okay let's
say it right you gotta you go to the
beach right I don't care about what you
like gone that's about me so I was about
to make a point and they just made you
just made it seem like I just made an AI
generator sentence I like the ocean I
like the ocean
the Cadence of what you were talking
about
what happened was I was starting my
sentence I was like oh Connor hasn't
finished this point and then you stopped
and I was like well because now I
realize okay okay it's like you go okay
let's say you go to the beach right yeah
like if you go in shoes it feels gross
feels nasty I don't like it okay if you
sit down on it I gotta Samuel's all the
way man you gotta go to the beach yeah
right that's fine we can go in sandals
yeah I mean I love my vessels man but
not for the beach man not for the beach
it's like then like you let's say you
lay a towel down towel gets all [__]
Sandy I hate that I hate that so much
tell that Sandy if you're like new to
the beach well I mean it's pretty it's
pretty easy to avoid getting saved but
then like let's say I go into the ocean
I want to dry myself and it's like okay
that's why you're bringing up the towel
yeah yeah but this is already this is
already so annoying life hack bring two
towels this is already so frustrating
that I have to drink two towels and then
like I don't know I think it's worth
going through all that just for The
Vibes there's just something about a
beachfly like that you can't because I
actually agree with you I do not like
sand and I don't like swimming in the
ocean but yet I love beaches just
because there is just a certain Vibe
especially when you can feel the Ocean
Air there's just something about this
this is like it's a living yeah yeah
this is living man and I say that
growing up in Brighton we have one of
the worst beaches I've been to in the
world uh I mean every British Beach is
the worst Beach I've been in the world
but I still [__] loved it
something about being next to a big body
of water is just especially during covid
and especially living in Tokyo I miss
that a lot you know because we we have
beaches here in Japan uh but unless you
go you know down south yeah it's not
like great beaches yeah
um not a fan of beaches it's kind of
where I'm I don't know like I I could
enjoy the beach more if I like
let's say I went like Giga bougie and we
had like a a like we're staying like an
Airbnb yeah like access to the beach
yeah then I'm kind of down because then
act like a beach resort because then you
just go back into the hotel or whatever
when you're done like yeah it's the
whole like traveling to the beach which
I also hate a lot of the time because
you gotta like you're like you you're
dressed for the beach but you don't want
to I don't want to dress as an
Australian I'm dying on the inside this
is like this is the average Australian
commute yeah this is basically I hate
that I think it's just the British that
pardoned me that just hates it yeah and
so are there not any beaches in Wales uh
there are but they're so there's some
there's one really nice in South Wales
called like the Gower or mumbles it's
called and it's pretty nice yeah and
it's like this but it's more of like a
looks like a Game of Thrones Stone
formation it's like a giant place it
looks amazing it's right right but it's
not really like a maybe in the summer
you go there but I never did I just went
there to like walk across the beautiful
thing yeah there's some up north at a
pretty decent but a lot of them are
terrible a lot of needles a lot of
stones they stink yeah the tide like
difference is crazy oh really yeah
um yeah don't go to England for his
beaches or just Britain in general I
don't think anyone wants here that's why
we go outside not even British people do
yeah yeah but then if you don't have the
beach if you're not a big beach guy and
you also kind of don't Vibe with the
city of like Waikiki in Hawaii
what's everybody to do so we ended up
drinking craft beer most of the time
yeah that's right which was great that
was great the food no I was amazing yeah
that was probably the best part of one
one thing that I was really impressive
was the actual locals man oh yeah
everyone's really nice everyone had such
an awesome energy to them in Hawaii the
amount of times I did this while I was
there man I was just like I get this now
I don't know why locals do this this is
the vibe of Hawaii 100 it is totally
Vibes and everyone is just on the same
level I thought people would be like
much more relaxed over there but they
bring the energy and it's such a it's a
relaxed [__] energy yeah yeah I've
never seen such a relaxer relax run they
need to be in their hype when they want
yeah people were generally just a lot
happier there which was nice I felt a
little bit safer as well than most of
the US yeah
um I don't know if it is or if that's
just like a weird misconception I think
it's just purely because we're in
Waikiki but like I feel yeah compared to
other big cities and other American
states like yeah it was weird because I
almost forgot at one point I was like oh
we're in America yeah technically why do
I feel so safe just like well walking
around you realize you're in America
when there's like four lanes yeah cars
and you're like oh I'm back but I could
have but like there were so many days
where I would just be like I'm just
gonna go for a walk you know even if
it's at night or whatever right yeah you
couldn't catch me doing that in L.A or
on the mainland anywhere like or on the
mainland anyway right but in Hawaii for
some reason I was like yeah no it's no
one has a gun Here No One's Gonna stab
me here it's like everyone's just
chilling out when you know there's
definitely no guarantee Mainland sounds
so cool to say yeah yeah Attack on Titan
the mainland standing on the Baseline
foreign
do I find my enemies over there in L.A
it was good though I mean I enjoyed it
uh it was definitely the people that I I
liked the most yeah out of all of the
like everything about Hawaii and the
food the food and food people were the
best yeah yeah I'm like the weather was
pretty good we had a lot of rain but I I
like that generally not a fan of humid
in hot places actually I say that I live
in Japan yeah um but I'm an AC fiend
here I don't leave AC areas I'm actually
a fan of tropical I know you are yeah
it's a Thai though that's not fair yeah
it's got a natural buff to it it's not
just about being tired
[__] off it is about people you were
born in the warm rain look look I won't
have anything is better than British
rain okay British rain is the most
depressing thing I've seen on the face
of this Earth all right like there's
there's a difference between like the
[__] cold wet rain that's not even
really rain it's just like someone blew
of Razz like God blew of raspberry on
you bro it's just unpleasant to go out
versus just getting like rain that just
cools down the temperature by a few
degrees and it's just oh he says that
but the day before we left there was a
flood warning and it was torrential rain
it was it was pretty bad yeah I think
because when you're in Ireland and like
the middle of the Pacific Ocean yeah the
rain is so weird it like appears for
like five seconds yeah no jokes it's
like an on off switch sometimes just 10
seconds gone yeah again and then none
and then torrential gone it's so weird
in the UK if it rains it's like well
Susan uh get the biscuits and the scones
because it's gonna be raining for the
next four days and it's not gonna stop
and it's gonna be torrential yeah yeah
and it just doesn't stop uh yeah yeah
it's a no joke it's always raining and
yeah because we checked the weather
report uh just before we flew to Hawaii
and you know we saw the weather report
and we're getting worried because we had
a week-long like period or that was just
rain yeah but I knew what it meant if
it's like tropical weather just rain on
the weather report means it's going to
rain hard for five minutes I've then
ever and then for like the rest of like
the 24 hours maybe it'll rain in like
the night time yeah or the evening time
uh but it will come in like five minute
bursts or like 20 minutes at most and
then it will like clear up it will dry
up and if you got and uh if you're
outside for those five minutes well [__]
you you are getting soaked yeah no
nobody's nobody's carrying around an
umbrella here man you either leave with
an umbrella you can't just like pick one
up randomly sure